I've been real picky it's what it is
because even though I was in a business
I had a lot of choices to do a lot of
different films a lot of films I just
did not do because I didn't think that
they were going to do any good so I
turned them down
so that's why I wrote the book of my
life and I talked about all that stuff
yeah how did you do die hard for example
how did you get the call for that I did
I did I think I did lethal weapon before
that the same producers yeah and I did I
did one other film I can't think of the
name before that also the same producers
and so when when that came along that
the producer Joe Silver's called me up
to do it yeah so that's how I got on
that yeah it's one of those movies that
everyone kind of talks about it's really
kind of changing the way the action
movies a source of and the way they were
made did what kind of sense did you have
when you were working on it
well well on that thing I don't think I
did any stunts I think I just you know
that he just shot and killed me you know
so you know he had strangers because
different films do different things you
know they ask the different things they
said will you do this I said yeah I'll
do it
you know so that's what is it is during
films just do different things you know
sometimes you want to do more sometimes
you want to nothing you know so that's
strange to me but yeah but but then and
then I did rapid-fire and it is a will
you fight I said I'll fight you know so
that's that's what happened there yeah a
lot of times you don't get the
opportunity to do what you want to do
you know a lot of times the reference
producers will say this is what I want
you to do and that's all you end up
doing and that's what it is yeah did you
like any really physical getting down
I'm a stunt person I'm not an actor I'm
gonna stunt person you know so lucky why
ask me that i I just a basic I'm like a
man wishes a stunt man you know and
that's what I still feel I am what's a
stunt person yeah but there's not that
many some people that everyone kind of
knows their face when everyone
recognizes you don't though yeah yeah
yeah I don't I don't know why but yeah
yeah if I said you look a little
different than everybody else you know
yeah yeah yeah definitely but tell me
about Bill and Ted what was it like
working on that
well it was a lot of fun everything
about it was great you know Alex Alex
winters here great guy you know great
person you know and and everybody the
crew everybody on it was great it was a
fun film yeah
how is it playing Genghis Khan it looks
very good very good very good
and I think that's like one of the very
few films I do not die in yeah yeah what
about any of the movies which ones stand
out for you particular well I like Big
Trouble in Little China because again
everybody wins great John Carpenter is
fantastic and is a great man yeah so I
like that a lot
yeah but a lot of times I worked on I
was very happy with because I'm the type
of guy that if things aren't going right
I will walk off the film and a lot of
people say you can't do that and I said
you watch and I'll walk up a film you
know because some films are just weird
you know but if the film doesn't feel
right I will I will walk away you know
so yeah it's weird yeah well films have
you walked off oh I'm sorry
which films do you walk John what you
know I really don't want to say but I I
did walk off on some films that are very
big films and I'm glad that I walked on
them too but you know I don't think I
should say those names oh yeah did you
feel was it you glad you walked off
because of how the film turned out in
the end or because how what combination
of both because I you know things
weren't going right when I was working
on it and then when I saw the NDI I
saved myself well I'm glad I didn't even
work on that yeah so it's it's it's
weird I worked there's some films that I
don't want to name him but you know I
just actually I was with within one one
film odds with a stunt coordinator that
brought me on the film and he goes I
went to fight the lead actor you know
and I was more than happy to do it and
then the director went nuts and you know
you know him me and him just didn't get
along you know and so I you know I just
walked on the film you know yeah so yeah
you think your favorite director to work
with well well you know what again I
said John Carpenter was great I really
liked him a lot you know yeah he's a
great guy and big trouble was a lot of
fun cause everybody worked with with a
lot of fun to work with yeah and how
about actors we had to pick a couple of
actors who you've really enjoyed working
with well well you know what they tell
you to I I don't know one actor from the
next you know because like I said you
know I'm cent person you know and I just
go under just to work when they asked me
to do this I'll do it you know but but
there's nothing that I can't name an
actor that I can surface specifically
say this or that but I did work on Black
Rain and I will say that
Michael Douglas is a very nice guy man
he's so nice he will sit with the crew
and eat you know whereas a lot of the
big stars you know they go to own
trailers and I understand they won't do
their own thing but he'll sit right
there he'll stand in line is what you
know I'll you know he's the star you
know he won't stand from people just
stand in line with everybody else just
to go to lunch you know it's really
strange but great guy yeah but there's a
lot of actors I work with that I got to
say are very good though but he's a
stand-up because I said you know he
doesn't have to you know hang with just
a regular people you know and he always
does that which is great how did you get
into doing stunts in the first place um
I was a grip behind camera for three
years as a grip and and in Austin I
worked on a film and it the director
goes do you do you do any martial arts I
said yes I do and he says can you teach
these four girls how to do some martial
arts I said yes I can so I taught these
four girls how to do a home martial arts
thing and then so when they came to
shoot to see he goes get up there with
him and that's how it started
I had no intention in the business of
getting you know working in front of
camera and that was the one of the first
thing jail was that Shakti then when he
said to do that did you hesitate at all
no I didn't hesitate I you want me good
I got them doing so that's what happened
yeah no I didn't have to take yeah but
it was fine
and the rest is history as I say yeah I
guess that's what he did yeah cuz I had
no intention of being in it next thing I
know you know I've been in here for like
21 years and then you know I had a lot
of weird weird weird things go wrong and
I got out of it yeah it was very kind of
any of the stunts that were quite that
you had particular injuries or anything
like that Franck's I might it's quite a
dangerous profession to be in Israel I
have broken every rib at least twice and
you know my correct my sternum point
broke my arms and like everything's on a
lot of things on me I have been broken
before yeah you still here in one piece
still here in one piece yes but it's
been lovely to speak to yells like so
much taking the time have a great
weekend you too
you